kim Kardashian mais c'est un message et
comment elle a eu votre numéro mais là
tout le monde a mon numéro tous les gens
un peu importants
ça fait partie de mon groupe de
production kim Kardashian ça va je suis
pas content de ton travail on va se voir
2 minutes un jour elle dit bon je veux
rencontrer les actionnaires
suivant il m'appelle
kim Kardashian elle veut nous voir bon
je vais là-bas j'arrive à Kim Kardashian
elle est avec genre son manager tu vois
si ça va how are you
et de fil en aiguille elle me dit
qu'est-ce que tu fais je lui dis voilà
moi je suis pas con avec des gens
n'hésitez pas à quoi que le PSG je suis
ouais bien sûr que je suis pas encore le
PSG tu peux avoir des places je dis pas
cette année l'année prochaine il y a PSG
Rennes
[Applaudissements]